Jennifer Garner steps out all smiles
amid ex Ben Affleck's budding romance
this is a big deal
[Music]
the 45 year old actress was spotted
leaving a workout class in Los Angeles
California on Saturday looking happy as
ever rocking an all-black
athleisure wear ensemble she paired the
look with blue tennis shoes brown shades
and her hair pulled back into a braid
exciting this is the first sighting of
jen since the news broke ex ben is
dating Saturday Night Live producer
Lindsay shook us a source tells eetzi
they are just enjoying each other's
company right now and it seems Ben's new
lady love is as friendly with her ex as
he is with his new Dora bus window fire
the source also revealed shook us and
her ex Kevin Miller are amicably
separated and have filed for divorce the
pair share a young daughter and it's
quote not uncommon to see them together
getting coffee while Affleck and garner
recently spent the 4th of July holiday
with their three kids as a family
[Music]
you